cómo podemos convencer a los jóvenes de
nuestro país de dedicar su vida a
mejorar la de todos les cuenta resulta
que en el año 1963 el estado de west
virginia en eeuu cumplirá 100 años para
celebrarlo
un grupo de jóvenes decidió organizar un
campamento científico y aunque primero
pensaron en hacerlo en el campus de una
universidad un poco después de debatir
lo que implicaba tener a jóvenes
sentados por más de ocho horas
escuchando charlas aunque mejor no y
optaron por hacerlo en lo que llamaron
el gran laboratorio natural que era un
bosque federal entonces ahí pudieron
combinar charlas y experimentos con
actividades al aire libre
aunque se suponía que fuera cosa de una
sola vez para celebrar justamente el
centenario los ex participantes rogaron
que se siguiera haciendo porque había
sido una experiencia transformadora y
así fue hasta el año 1983 en el que se
creó una fundación para apoyar el
campamento
y ustedes se preguntarán para qué nos
estás contando todo esto y es que en el
año 2013 me tocó a mí un jueves a la
mañana recibí la llamada en la que me
decían que había quedado seleccionada
para representar nuestro país en este
místico campamento una beca completa mi
primer viaje internacional una gran
oportunidad y así fue que viajé este
campamento que estuvo zarpado la verdad
que cada día estaba diseñado para hacer
una sorpresa o sea literal no sabías que
te va a pasar hicimos desde disección de
cerebros hasta tener un concierto en una
cueva
y además era tremendamente personalizado
tipo no sé si les pasó alguna vez y dio
una conferencia y tener que agarrar un
cartelito escribir su nombre y
colocárselo como que tienen que ganarse
esa identificación de los demás pero en
el campamento no hasta mi cama tenía mi
nombre se sentía como que me estaban
esperando
al año siguiente empecé a estudiar
ingeniería y química en la universidad
tecnológica nacional pero había dos
intrigas que me habían quedado dando
vueltas en la cabeza y la primera tenía
que ver con cómo hace ese equipo o sea
seguir pensando la experiencia que había
vivido y pensaba cómo se organizan para
que todo esté 'minuto a minuto'
cronometrado porque les cuento éramos
más de 130 jóvenes de distintos países
de las américas a los que había que
entretener durante más de tres semanas
más pero entonces ya pensaba esta gente
no duerme o sea algunos se quedan
despiertos y trabajando y los otros
duermen como hacen para tener todo
planeado también me acuerdo que cuando
estuve en el campamento del estudio se
preguntar tipo que me tiren un tip de
cómo manejaba la logística pero un poco
de timidez y un inglés no muy
desarrollado me impidieron hacerlo
además con el tiempo entendí que algunos
aprendizajes para adquirir nos tenemos
que vivirlos y eso me lleva a mi segundo
interrogante que tiene que ver con poder
ser capaz de realizar una experiencia de
esa magnitud para otros jóvenes
argentinos
y en 2017 me lance a la aventura me
decidí a armar un evento único y
personalizado en el interior del
interior de la provincia de córdoba en
miramar de ansenuza porque yo también
tengo cerca un gran laboratorio natural
que es la laguna mar chiquita entonces
ahí convocamos a más de 30 delegadas con
becas completas y las reunimos con un
montón de oradores y la verdad es que
salió hermoso pero
pudo haber salido mejor y aunque
escuchen esto también era cosa de una
sola vez decidimos hacerlo un año más y
otro año más hasta que nosotros también
decidimos hacer una fundación para
bancar nuestro trabajo coincidencia
a todo esto mi carrera de ingeniería
seguía transcurriendo pero yo cada vez
me alejaba más del aula y me acercaba a
encontrar mi cara a cara con una fuerza
imparable que es la que me sembró el
sueño de crear una experiencia
transformadora para cada joven de
nuestro país
y es que yo creo que quienes las viven
son los que después tienen el poder de
transformar nuestras comunidades y creo
que es la educación la que nos da la
plataforma para crear estos escenarios
porque un momento inolvidable te puede
pasar en un campamento en un intercambio
o en un aula cuando un prophète saca la
ficha y te dice che vos tenés talento
para la música
dale por ahí no es mi caso no
creo que lo que tienen en común estas
experiencias es que te dejan una huella
en el corazón que es imposible de borrar
y que es una fuente de poder inagotable
y creo que lo que tienen en común son
dos ingredientes
el primero tiene que ver con que cada
vez tiene una experiencia zarpada hay
por detrás gente apasionada gente que
transpira que transmite ganas de vivir
por eso creo que quienes queremos
transformar el mundo a través de la
educación tenemos la responsabilidad de
compartir nuestros sueños en
vulnerabilidad porque cuando nosotros
nos animamos a darle a nuestros sueños
el valor que tienen y a mostrar cuánto
nos transforman cuando nosotros nos
animamos a brillar es como que validamos
al resto a encontrar su propia luz
por eso cada vez que organizó un
programa me gusta reunir a jóvenes con
jueguitos que arden diría galeano con
personas que se vuelven locas por una
idea o un proyecto y creo que a la
apatía al desinterés a la desconexión
que vemos a veces en nuestros jóvenes
más ahora en tiempos de pandemia las
podemos combatir sembrando en la mente
de cada estudiante la intriga de que la
vida esconde maravillas para aquellos
que se animan a materializar sus ideas
el segundo ingrediente tiene que ver con
la maestría del detalle porque hay que
lograr ese gesto ese entorno ese momento
que te cambia la vida para siempre y eso
se logra con la repetición y aprendiendo
de los errores y sé que no es fácil
porque muchas veces es más sencillo
abandonar un proyecto y dedicarnos a uno
nuevo más aún cuando estamos arrancando
y tenemos millones de cosas para hacer y
como diría gabriel salón de día esto es
el presidente porque estás liderando un
equipo y está respondiendo algunas
entrevistas pero a la noche también te
toca barrer la casa rosada
si alguien contará la cantidad de horas
que me pasó diseñando nuestros programas
minuto a minuto me deberían dar algún
tipo de récord
y aunque todo esto hace renegar y da
trabajo un montón porque hay que
organizar los eventos y armar las
autorizaciones y hay que llamar a las
chicas y hay paro de transporte y ahora
hay comida hay que hacer cosas virtuales
lo sigo eligiendo sin dudar sigo
eligiendo hacer experiencias únicas y
transformadoras para jóvenes de nuestro
país porque creo que con una sola de
ellas nos podemos convencer como les
decía de dedicar su vida a transformar
la de todos porque son esos momentos que
los jóvenes tienen la oportunidad de
vivir los que los convencen de hacer por
otros lo que alguien hizo por ellos
y aunque ya les conté un montón de las
cosas en las que creo les quiero contar
algo en lo que no creo que es en las
coincidencias
el año pasado se hizo un programa que se
llamó ciencia fuera de la caja y frank
uno de los participantes quedó entre los
25 finalistas
me enorgullece contarles que ese
programa lo organizó nuestra fundación y
que le alegró la cuarentena a un par de
cientos de jóvenes argentinos pero como
si esto fuera poco frank este año quedó
seleccionado para representar a nuestro
país en el campamento de west virginia
en el mismo que yo
y yo elijo creer que no nada es porque
sí que no es fortuita la conexión de
frank entre estos dos programas ni que
es casualidad que como haya siguieron
haciendo el campamento acá también
creamos una fundación para seguir
acompañando nuestro trabajo creo que
cada vez somos más los que queremos
contagiar ganas a propósito porque
entendimos que si cuando la vida nos da
limones hay que hacer limonada cuando la
vida nos regala oportunidades nos está
dando en realidad el poder de
multiplicar los